i want to start by talking about this
very unique experience i just had my
wife liza wrote a play oh called
apostrophe and she got a production of
it up on whidbey island wow which was
really fun the play's terrific
cass is amazing really proud of my wife
one of the cool things is it's a very
small town i was wandering around this
small town and i immediately started to
get to know everybody because i stick
out a little bit
so
it starts with just people in town
saying hi and then i go to sit down at
one point and i'm there not very long
uh when the police chief walks by this
very nice very cool guy a chief javier
wasser i meet him we start chatting
lovely guy we strike up a friendship the
next thing i know he's saying would you
like to meet the mayor and he said yeah
i'd like to meet the mayor sure the
answer
to do you want to meet the mayor is yes
yeah i want to meet the mayor
so i say yes i want to meet the mayor
and he says great
and then we exchanged numbers then i'm
texting the police chief back and forth
and also thinking i've got to get out of
jail free card i know yeah i was just
thinking that so you could speed oh i
yeah i stole things
it was a crime spree to do a little
murder
maybe there was a little murder yeah you
don't have this
let's just say i dabbled in murder okay
um i dipped my toe in murder all right
anyway
uh we're back and forth and then he says
yeah come on by the city hall at two i'm
walking around and then it starts to get
to be near two o'clock and i'm with my
daughter and then i'm thinking where's
the city hall and someone comes rushing
out of their store and they go oh hi
conan i'm headed over to your ceremony
and i'm like
i said
do you know where city hall is and she
says yeah everything is one block away
from everything else it's right there
so we go over and sure enough they've
planned i get a tour police chief
introduces me to the mayor and then um
we get shown through the the city hall
people are incredibly nice and then they
have a crowd out behind city hall
and they have an impromptu ceremony and
they dedicate a trash can to me
what yes i'm the talking trash can here
i know highway robbery yeah and so
there's a trash can there and they very
quickly
the mayor had a speech
what that um he found someone in town to
write for him and then i met the kid who
wrote the speech and i said so he looks
like he's about 19. he's wearing a
little bow tie and he said so you worked
for the mirror and went oh no the mayor
just saw me
getting buying a cappuccino and said i
need a speech for conan o'brien
induction you know into the trash can
hall of fame so is that an honor
yeah you know
i think the the thing to do is to just
say yes it is okay so okay they um they
quickly i mean it's kind of a joke but
they just put a sign on it that said the
kona cam
and
um
now mike sweeney who used to uh he and
his his uh lovely wife cynthia they both
flew up to see this play
because uh they're they're tight with
with liza as well
and so they came up and mike sweeney's
the writer uh you know sort of lead
field guy who has done all of the conan
travel shows yeah so mike swinney hears
that i'm doing this and he rushes over
from his airbnb
and he's like okay i've got some jokes
for you i've got some things you could
do and i'm going to shoot it and then
he's shooting it wildly with his iphone
i think hey our travel shows are back
after
two and a half years of covid we're back
and this is your return i'm on whidbey
island
with the mayor and it's totally
something we would have done in one of
our travel shows completely something we
would have done we would like to
dedicate this trash can that has long
served our community to a person that
embodies civil service
as much as the trash can itself the city
of langley has long been looking for a
person to dedicate this
icon of civil service to you
and when we heard that conan o'brien had
decided to visit our humble retirement
community in celebration of his own
retirement
so
we have that experience and they asked
me to sign the trash can they give me a
sharpie so i drew a little conan and i
write what an honor you know and then i
sign it and date it and it's an actual
trash can that's going to be there at
whidbey island for the foreseeable
future until they honor the next person
who comes to town
but i had that experience and i thought
this is really fantastic and then i'm
like feeling kind of full of myself
and
just because it's a big experience a
heavy experience and i'm
and also just a little dazed you know a
little like we flew up there i didn't
get much sleep my my wife's got this
play i'm gonna go see that in about an
hour and i'm a little just off kilter
and i'm walking down the street and
these two guys these two kids see me
they look like sort of you know maybe
19.
and they one of them turns around and
goes whoa conan o'brien and i said oh
hey guys and they're like wow we heard
you were in town we didn't believe it
this is crazy and i went yeah well nice
talking to you and they're like you nice
talking to you too and then i wanted to
say something afterwards
and i don't know why i said this but i
wrote it down in my journal i wrote have
some good time oh no
oh i wrote it down
have some good time they must have
thought like some imposter conan o'brien
had come to the island where it's like
we couldn't afford the real conan
o'brien
i think you were desperate to find
something to say to them and i didn't
have it i didn't have it and i remember
just started turning around and going
have some good time
and then i turned back and i'm walking
and i turned to my daughter and i said
have some good time was she embarrassed
she was just shook her head like that
was not good you were up there
you were doing really great no i was
killing it i had you know chief wasser
yeah on my speed dial mayor i'm you know
elevated to the point where i get my own
trash can you flipped you've peaked i
peaked and then i had it
and
i was walking away from these kids and i
shout out have some good times that's
because and it's over now yeah yeah
because you peeked at the trash can and
it's downhill from there it's also
you're i i get this you're so desperate
not you but in general one is so
desperate not me
very desperate to think to make
teenagers think they're cool yeah and
you
they thought you were cool you had them
i had it you said have some good time
and then they were like oh we thought he
was cool but you know what it reminded
me of you know when you're in a country
china or korea and they or japan they do
that thing where they
they use english words but it doesn't
quite make sense
like hooray good fun noodles
you'll see that i made one of those
i speak english yeah and i was born here
and i said have some good time you
turned into a.i conan it was k.i conan
yeah yeah oh man anyway i think the
slogan for conan o'brien needs a friend
should be have some good time that's a
great slogan i like have some good time
yeah man